[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
auditions publiques un invité une heure
chaque semaine à 19h30 le lundi sur LCP
Public Sénat et notre invité cette
semaine c'est Alexis Corbière soyez le
bienvenue merci le député LFI de
Seine-Saint-Denis à tous cette
invitation puis à tous ceux qui nous
regardent une année j'espère heureuse et
vous êtes d'autant plus bienvenue c'est
à l'orée d'une semaine importante quelle
semaine je dis tout commence pour la
contestation de la réforme des retraites
d'Emmanuel Macron la mobilisation sera
forte grâce à l'Union Syndicale
sera-t-elle historique de façon à
installer une dynamique durable on le
verra 68% des Français pensent que la
réforme sort à voter et appliquée est-ce
que visible vous y voyez une résignation
comme un frein à la contestation ce
combat pourrait les filles devraient
être l'occasion de disqualifier ce
deuxième quinquennat ce second
quinquennat macroniste est-ce que ce
sera le cas et puisqu'on note c'est
qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de sujet
annexe mais très important qui pollue
votre actualité politique à la Nupe et à
LFI elle a faire quatre nyces il y a
votre éviction avec d'autres de
l'exécutif du mouvement il y a la
rentrée jugée catastrophique en termes
d'audience de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur
France 2 la semaine dernière et puis un
parti socialiste qui pourrait s'éloigner
de la nuque si Olivier fort n'était pas
reconduit jeudi rien n'est fait mais
tout de même la menace est là quelle
semaine oui mais risqué aussi pour vous
Brigitte boucher Tam traduit vont
revenir sur l'essentiel de la réforme
des retraites Yves Thréard révoquera les
grands enjeux politiques pour vous
Vincent roult les questions d'actualité
mais la réforme des retraites on va
commencer tous les deux si vous voulez
en introduction elle sera adoptée et
mise en oeuvre Martel le gouvernement
vous allez me dire que non mais je
reviens à ce chiffre de 68% quand même
il me frappe de Français qui pensent
aussi quelle sera votée et adoptée
est-ce que ça n'est pas un sacré frein
ça à la mobilisation cette intérior
parler français 68% presque 70 qu'elle
va passer et le même chiffre dit que 68%
des Français sont opposés et même quand
on interroge ceux qui sont des actifs
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne prennent pas en
compte nos retraités que nous aimons
mais vraiment les actifs qui sont
directement concernés c'est 93% qui sont
opposés à cette réforme et on va
commencer notre échange sur ce point-là
sur l'aspect démocratique on va échanger
tout à l'heure sur la pertinence ou non
et vous avez résumé je suis un opposant
à cette réforme je souhaite son retrait
je pense que cela apaiserait le pays
mais on va en parler tout à l'heure mais
d'abord sur le plan de démocratique moi
je considère que quand il y a un tel
rejet de la part de la population quand
il y a uneanimité des organisations
syndicales de salariés je dis bien
uneanimité ce qui n'était pas arrivé
depuis plus de 12 ans contre cette
réforme quand manifestement le
gouvernement pense qu'il n'est pas très
à l'aise pour avoir une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale nous sommes dans
les murs l'Assemblée nationale à tel
point qu'il utilise
l'article 47-1 de la Constitution qui
est assez inédite et qui permet
soit les résultats des débats au terme
de 50 jours pas 51 50 jours
pourquoi ça me pose problème parce que
je pense que nous sommes dans un moment
au-delà de ce débat sur les retraites
donc grande doute sur la démocratie en
France moi c'est ce que je vois quand je
discute avec beaucoup des gens ça ne
s'agit c'est à dire que les gens ne vont
plus voter 10 millions d'absentionnistes
au premier tour 13 millions en seconde
je ne l'oublie pas des élections
municipales ou plus de 50% d'abstention
c'était même 30% de participation la
dernière fois et attention à ce qu'au
bout d'un moment les grandes décisions
qui concernent les gens quand elles leur
sont imposées ça donne l'impression que
ça ne sert plus à rien d'aller voter et
la violence ou d'autres modes
d'organisation de la société peuvent
émerger et je ne le souhaite première
fois Alexis Corbière qu'une réforme
provoque des manifestations de rue des
contestations et que finalement la
représentation nationale finit par la
voter ça ne renverse pas ça ne
disqualifie pas en tout cas ça n'a
moindrait pas la démocratie vous avez
dit et la représentation nationale finit
par la beauté je il y a une singularité
dans ce deuxième quinquennat Macron
c'est qu'il n'a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale je ne sous-estime
pas ça sur une telle réforme qui est
sans doute une réforme les plus dures
sur les vrais femmes de retraite
précédente je pense que non seulement
c'est le moment de la démocratie sociale
et de grâce merci de Madame Arthur de ne
pas l'avoir dit mais que c'est ce
vocabulaire que j'entends prise d'otage
blocage de pays non
avec son histoire de mobilisation
sociale écoutons les Français et si même
pourquoi pas je le mets ça sur la table
c'est Fabien Roussel qui en avait parlé
et pourquoi pas conclure si je puis dire
ou avoir que pour état de la
mobilisation un référendum pour
consulter
qui est ministre du budget des comptes
publics dit que vous avez vous êtes le
camp du blocage est-ce que vous assumez
alors précisément cette discussion est
intéressante monsieur Attal va-t-il en
vacances sans doute et je le lui
souhaite si le bénéficie de congés c'est
grâce à un moment de greffe dans le pays
en 1936 que j'apprends quand j'étais
professeur d'histoire aux élèves donc
c'est ce vocabulaire pour faire peur il
y aura pas de blocage il va y avoir
exercice de la démocratie qui s'appelle
le droit de grève et par contre ça passe
par le blocage une grève réussie est-ce
qu'elle passe par un blocage
d'une grève réussie quand il y a
beaucoup de gens qui font grève ou non
l'activité s'arrête et on s'aperçoit un
truc incroyable pour Monsieur Attal
c'est que ceux qui font tourner le pays
ceux qui font tourner son métro les
enseignants qui prennent ces enfants etc
etc sont des êtres humains et quand ils
arrêtent de travailler et ben ça marche
plus alors ça bloque peut-être sa
pénalise
d'abord une non attendez ne posez pas
les gens et je veux dire les Français
c'est aussi ceux qui font et la première
pénalisation qu'il subisse c'est quand
on fait grève on a pu on n'est pas payé
durant sa journée donc monsieur Attal
devrait avoir un vocabulaire comment
dirais-je plus serein plus démocrate
ça va pas bloquer le pays ça va exercer
quelque chose de magnifique qui est sans
doute un critère pour examiner si une
société démocratique ou pas le droit de
grève les salariés se sont battus pour
ça au cours du 19e siècle pour l'obtenir
nous avons conquis des belles conquêtes
sociales et je ne veux pas ce
vocabulaire de soi-disant pardon mais on
est j'ai même entendu des gens dire le
pays va être pris en otage comme aussi
quasiment il y avait des terroristes on
a compris votre argumentaire c'est un
vocabulaire méprisant pour le peuple ça
manque de respect
arrogant
agressifs en face de vous bonsoir
mesdames bonsoir on va parler de cette
mobilisation jeudi et oui
et bonne semaine tous les deux sont déjà
tournés bien sûr sur la journée de
mobilisation de jeudi quel est votre
objectif de mobilisation c'est alors
parce que ça a fait l'objet d'une
discussion sont les syndicats qui
appellent à cette journée je les
applaudis je les salue et je trouve que
c'est bien qu'il fasse l'unité donc je
ne parle pas à leur place j'ai entendu
des chiffres qui sont donnés par
Monsieur berger monsieur Martinez un
demi-millions voir un million a été dit
cet objectif que eux se fixent moi je
souhaite qu'il y ait le plus de monde
possible et vous comprenez que mon rôle
vous dites pas en dessous du million
c'est un échec parce que c'est pas un
objectif chiffré pour deux raisons
premièrement parce que en dessous d'un
million même ce ne serait pas un échec
deuxièmement parce que je ne veux pas je
suis pas comme c'est quoi la Gren
les syndicats c'est ce que vous nous
dites il y a pas la volonté d'être
vraiment tous ensemble en cette journée
de jeudi c'est vraiment les syndicats en
première ligne ça vous dérange pas tous
ensemble précisément c'est dans ce rôle
bien compris de ce qu'est une journée
d'action syndicale c'est-à-dire le
politique est là en soutien et n'est pas
en première ligne de la même façon que
les organisations syndicales je crois
nous en remercie parce que je les ai
entendu le dire que nous sommes lundi
demain soir il y aura à Paris un meeting
politique nu-pesz la même façon que nous
avons nous organisé la journée du 21 qui
est un samedi à l'appel de regagnation
mais je dise les organisations
syndicales samedi c'est plus politique
si je puis dire une dernière question
sur cette journée de jeudi un nombre qui
plane sur cette manifestation c'est
d'être débordé par les violences des
Black Blocs c'est ta crainte encore ce
jeudi est-ce que vous avez des
informations à ce sujet sur
l'organisation pour faire face à ce
risque moi j'ai pas d'information mais
je ne souhaite vraiment pas que de
violence je sais que les organisations
syndicales se donnent les moyens
d'éviter ça je dis à ce le parent et je
pense qu'il m'écoutent pas mais ceux qui
viendraient casser nous rendrait service
qu'au gouvernement premièrement notre
force ce sera trop nombre et notre
caractère pacifique notre puissance sera
la puissance du peuple mobilisée
tranquillement mais qui dit des choses
et toutes choses qui amènerait de la
violence de la case de la destruction
non seulement est stupide pour ce qui
est détruit parce que ça n'a rien et
deuxièmement ne donnerait qu'une image
je vois bien comment c'est un jeu de
communication une journée d'action
comment en fin de journée si c'est pour
dire regarder c'est des brutes et des
barbares bon ça ne rime à rien donc moi
la force à laquelle j'aspire selon vous
c'est pas tout à fait ce que j'ai dit je
pense qu'il y a des gens s'ils le font
ils ont tort et par ailleurs l'histoire
aussi du mouvement ouvrier comme on dit
pour faire en sorte que cette
manifestation ne soit pas débordée alors
le préfet de Paris a changé et je pense
que Monsieur l'allemand était dans le
moins mauvaise disposition je sais pas
comment le dire était le nouveau préfet
dont je cherche le nom Laurent munes
plus raisonnable sur ces comment dire
maintien de l'ordre utilisation des
forces de l'ordre
j'aimerais à ce stade je pense que c'est
un homme qui a comment dirais-je plus de
sang-froid dans l'exercice de ça
nécessite aussi un professionnelisme et
n'a pas ce rapport de d'aller au contact
comme le préfet l'allemand le demander
nombre de vos confrères le montrer dans
certains articles où il fallait que ce
soit violent beaucoup de gens ont été
tes blessés il y a même des procédures
judiciaires ou sans doute monsieur
l'allemand ça ramené à rendre des
comptes donc je dis à Monsieur Nunès il
va y avoir beaucoup de monde aider les
organisations et dès ce droit tout
simplement de droit de manifester à
avoir lieu et je dis à ceux qui viennent
casser bien vous ne serez pas les
bienvenus si vous venez pour en quelque
sorte essayer de de troller comme disent
les jeunes aujourd'hui la manifestation
c'est une manifestation pacifique donc
là manifestation du 19 il y en a une le
21 ça c'est la nupes qu'il appelle de
ses vœux organisations
de jeunesse et la France insoumise et le
secteur jeunesse de en France apporte
son plein soutien donc samedi qui n'est
pas une journée à l'appel des
organisations syndicales samedi il y
aura aussi cette ce moment fort une
autre journée
finale vous dites ce sont les syndicats
qui doivent être en première ligne pour
dénoncer la réforme des retraites alors
pourquoi cette journée-là et pourquoi
finalement ne pas l'avoir annuler parce
que ce n'est pas sur le même plan de la
même façon que je le dis tout à l'heure
je vais le répéter alors actuelle il y a
une myriade de meeting qui vont se tenir
à travers la France nupes politiques
d'accord les organisations syndicales
font leur boulot nous politiquement on
fait notre boulot demain soir à Japy il
y a meeting parisien où tous les numéros
cette manifestation deux jours après ce
que vous appelez l'acné la mobilisation
parce que précisément je crois que si
elle s'opposait si elle disait que
c'était la même chose que le 19 elle ne
serait pas utile c'est-à-dire que le 19
ça va être une journée de grève qui
peut-être même ils vont se réunir le
soir du 19e siècle
samedi et que les choses en plus ça
c'était prévu avant les vacances de Noël
dans un moment où les organisations
syndicales n'avaient pas donné de date
des organisations de jeunesse à 19 vous
auriez pu de revenir dessus
ça ne nécessite pas de se mettre en
grève pour manifester samedi il y aura
aussi du monde samedi mais je le répète
pour ma part l'élément phare et vous
l'aurez compris c'est le 19 j'ai mis
tous les Français tous ceux qui nous
regardent à faire enregistrer beaucoup
de monde le 19 vous ne craignez pas vous
qui a un flop le 21 que justement elle
apparaisse un peu moins moins
discutablement mais ça ne sera pas une
journée inutile et sera une spécificité
jeune pas l'appel d'organisation
syndicale de salariés alors Fabien
Roussel lui dit c'est un cheval dans la
soupe avec ses gros sabots cette journée
du du 21 il se désolidarise de la nuque
écoutez moi à l'heure actuelle
deux jours après non mais parce que si
on le concevait si la France insoumise
posée cette journée comme étant de même
nature que la journée 19 nous ferions
une erreur d'accord moi j'ai été le
premier dans ses locaux à l'occasion
d'une conférence de presse à dire aux
organisations syndical lorsque la date
du 19e c'était pas sortie donnez-nous
votre date ce sera la note donc le 21
n'est pas sur le même plan d'accord et
si les insoumis disaient
21 19 = 21 ce serait une erreur ça c'est
une chose donc ce sera une journée à
l'appel de régnation de jeunesse qui
permettra de pour ceux qui ne se mettent
pas en grève peut-être de venir aussi
deuxièmement ce que je dis et Fabien
Roussel moi j'ai des bonnes relations le
comprendra à l'heure actuelle j'invite
chacun et ça me servira peut-être de fil
conducteur pour tout à l'heure quand
vous me titillerez sur d'autres sujets à
se concentrer sur l'unité à l'heure
actuelle sur la question des de la
réforme des retraites à être utile
Fabien Roussel notamment sera meeting
ou sur tous les sujets ça concerne
tellement toute la vie des gens la
question des retraites
vient l'heure de l'action ça arrive il y
a des moments faut être un peu militaire
et ceux qui ont l'heure de l'action
lorsque je veux dire c'est que si on en
est il faut être efficace c'est pas le
moment où quand on vous dit maintenant
on avance tous quand on parle qui disent
mais peut-être que moi j'avais envie
d'avoir de faire ça un autre vous allez
poursuivre en parallèle vos journées
comme celle du 21 en parallèle de celle
du 19 donc qu'est-ce qui se passe après
c'est quoi la mobilisation d'après vous
et moi nous allons le découvrir le 19
attentivement on va regarder laissez-moi
terminer que les organisations
syndicales vont se réunir pour tirer le
bilan de cette journée est-ce un succès
le parler du million intéressant à quoi
appelle-t-elle est-ce que par exemple ce
qui peut arriver si c'est un succès peut
même appeler à une grève reconductible
dès le lendemain et le pays peut se
mettre en grève générale incroyable ou
alors considérer il y a aussi une
dialectique de la mobilisation qu'il
faut vous le souhaitez moi je
souhaiterais quelque chose de massif qui
règle le problème le plus rapidement
possible et qui fait que ce gouvernement
et couper leur soupir du gouvernement
écoutez moi je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
je pense que au-delà de la pertinence de
cette réforme on est dans un moment où
l'inflation est là les gens vivent au
monde difficile d'inquiétude généralisée
ou franchement le prix du caddie a pris
une sacrée augmentation c'est pas le
moment de venir brutaliser le pays et de
ficher la planète Jean-Luc a dit ça
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous appelez à la
grève générale je répète mes chers
Brigitte boucher que je ne me prends pas
pour un dirigeant syndical je pense
qu'elle sera un outil et que si les
confédérations Sénégal en fonction du
rapport de France je pense c'est un
outil utile de point de vue du droit des
libertés syndicales pour dire au
gouvernement pour se faire entendre la
grève la grève générale on va parler un
peu du fond de cette réforme vous dites
c'est une réforme violente bon il y a
quand même des dispositions pour la
retraite à 1200 euros pour tous les
retraités y compris actuels des
dispositions sur les carrières longues
sur les carrières hachées des femmes en
plus c'est beaucoup plus progressif que
ce qu'il y avait de prévu initialement
ce qu'il n'y a vraiment rien à sauver
dans cette réforme pour vous
malgré tout le respect que je vous donne
que vous avez dit n'est pas exact
d'accord premièrement les 1200 euros qui
est l'élément de communication qui est
dit ça ne concerne que les retraités qui
ont une carrière complète d'accord
mais c'est pas parce que moi il y a des
gens âgés qui ont entendu que tout le
monde allait être à 1200 euros non ce
n'est pas le cas deuxièmement c'est pas
tout à fait 1200 euros parce que c'est
sans aucun doute qu'il y aura la CSG qui
va être payé là-dessus c'est 85 % du
SMIC à l'heure actuelle net c'est du
brut et c'est ça
va voir la pension de retraite augmenter
je vais peut-être un million et alors et
je termine le gouvernement dit 2
millions au 1er septembre c'est pas tout
à fait avéré mais c'est pas grave de
toute manière je vais rassurer tout le
monde non non mais je conteste même pas
ce que je par contre ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'était l'article 4 de la loi
de 2003 de Monsieur Fillon il n'y a pas
besoin de faire travailler des millions
de gens deux ans de plus pour mettre en
application quelque chose qui était déjà
prévu dans la loi et que Monsieur Macron
n'avait pas mis en application notamment
en 2017 non plus que les gouvernements
précédents donc ce que je vais vous dire
c'est je vois bien l'élément de
communication qui est donné mais tout de
même premièrement les gens vont quand
même travailler deux ans de plus et
c'est la moindre des choses qu'ils aient
une pension peut-être un petit peu plus
importante parce qu'ils vont les payer
par leur travail et aussi les retraités
actuels pardon pas que les retraités
futurs les retraités actuels auront 100
€ de plus par contre ce que ce que je
dis c'est que si vous voulez faire
travailler les gens plus longtemps parce
que c'est le cœur du sujet aujourd'hui
on a un faible taux d'emploi de nos
seniors autour de 55 ans j'ai participé
à une réunion au ministère du Travail
monsieur du soft et c'est à ce moment-là
c'était au début des discussions le
constat qui a été fait qui est un
problème c'est à dire que beaucoup les
gens perdent leur emploi et les
entreprises n'auraient embauchent pas
les seniors le gouvernement propose un
index senior propose des mesures tout le
monde comprendra ces mécaniques qu'à
partir du moment où vous repoussez qu'il
faut encore plus de cotisations par quel
effet magique d'un seul coup les patrons
vont dire ah je ne licencie plus à 55
ans ou du moins j'embauche je vais
m'embaucher des gens plus âgés
mécaniquement
ce qui est avéré c'est quand on est
passé de 60 à 62 ans on a eu beaucoup de
gens qui sont tombés dans la pauvreté
notamment enfin qui sont des
bénéficiaires du RSA sur les plus âgés
qui a fortement augmenté je crois qu'il
est montré après de 300000 personnes
tout le monde le sait donc on est là
face à une difficulté qui va sans aucun
doute rallonger cette période de SAS
comme on dit on est quand même jusqu'à
72 ans c'est le fond du sujet
c'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir encore plus
d'années de travail ça va percuter en
particulier ceux qui ont commencé taux
qui vont devoir travailler encore plus
longtemps on va avoir mécaniquement
votre attitude sur un point précis par
exemple sur la pénibilité est-ce que
vous allez complètement vous opposer ou
est-ce que vous allez contribuer à
améliorer les critères de pénibilité
s'il y a un travail qui est bien
effectué là-dessus à travers ce projet
de loi on portera effectivement de
mettre tes critères de pénibilité mais
ce cas de cocase dans la situation c'est
que pendant le quinquennat précédent
c'est les mêmes qui ont supprimé les
critères
aujourd'hui maintenant est-ce que vous
vous en voulez bien construire moi je
veux bien rajouter des critères de
pénibilité sans aucun doute et nous
ferons ce travail là mais qu'on
comprenne bien de quelle manière il est
quand même un peu piquant que les mêmes
qui ont supprimé les critères de
pénibilité vient nous dire
on verra ce qui bougera ce qui bougera
je vais vous dire il faut être menace
c'est pas le traitement le travail
parlementaire on va le faire pleinement
et sérieusement mais c'est ce qui se
passe jeudi c'est tout si le pays se
mobilise sans aucun doute à moins que ce
gouvernement veuille avoir un bras de
fer avec la grande majorité de sa
population mais sans conduite
mais ce que moi je propose c'est qu'il
retire son texte parce qu'ils compris
vous êtes des techniciennes de la vie
parlementaire avouez que c'est un peu
baroque de d'aborder la question des
retraites à l'occasion d'un projet de
loi de finances de la sécurité sociale
ça avait été mis en place à l'époque
j'ai oublié de l'année où ça a été mis
en place c'était peut-être déjà son
Fillon il avait été dit que ça ne
pouvait pas concerner la question de la
durée des cotisations sur les ressources
sauf que on va passer par un projet de
Loire rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale donc il y a un temps limité 50
jours au total pour faire adopter cette
réforme est-ce que vous allez faire de
l'obstruction ou est-ce que vous allez
contribuer à ce débat parlementaire à se
débattre démocratique sur les retraites
je vais être obligé à nous mais Brigitte
boucher c'est incroyable que vous
utilisez le vocabulaire d'obstruction
alors que cette méthode même 47
revendique l'obstruction et dit il
pourrait y avoir un millier
d'amendements par député d'abord les
mots vous savez on t'en sens en
politique l'obstruction c'est
l'utilisation du 47-1 c'est-à-dire qui
dit que quel que soit ce que pensent que
vous jouez avec les mots la question
d'origine elle est simple dans un
millier d'amendements par députés qui
vous intéresse non mais attendez c'est
que je vois bien c'est la même
discussion attendez c'est la même
discussion que sur blocage vous
renversez vous renversez la question est
simple le principe qui est assumé par ma
petite panneau c'est celui-là est-ce que
c'est un million d'amendements de toute
manière en bonjour ça doit être terminé
nous allons déposer des amendements nous
ne sommes pas là pour permettre au
gouvernement d'aller vite maintenant je
veux que les Français comprennent qui à
l'utilisation sur un texte qui va les
concerner de l'outil constitutionnel qui
sont des traits autoritaires à mon avis
de cette Constitution qui méprise le
Parlement je le dis parce que c'est la
continuité de 10 utilisations du 49-3 et
je dis aux habitants de ce pays si vous
aimez la République vous aimez le
parlementarisme c'est pas le sujet que
ce que pensent les députés c'est votre
vie à vous ne tolérez pas en
gouvernement qui veut vous imposer une
réforme et à me permettant même pas que
le Parlement puisse en parler donc ce
que je fais après avec Mathilde pano
avec les autres le fait de déposer des
amendements ce sera incroyable qu'on
vient de me dire monsieur Corbière vous
ne permettez pas le débat parlementaire
alors que le gouvernement de toute
manière a considéré que quel que soit ce
que je fais c'est d'ailleurs voilà
je respectais la démocratie Emmanuel
Macron a été élu sur un projet un
programme avec la retraite à 65 ans et
64 ans entre les deux tours vous le
respectez ça ou pas mais écoutez quand
il a été lui Emmanuel Macron il a été
élu sur deux tours vous en souvenez
premier tour dans lequel il a fait 26 ou
27% des déçu
et au second tour je m'en souviens il a
été élu face à Madame Le Pen et il a ce
moment-là appelé toute une série de gens
à voter pour lui même s'ils ne partagent
pas à quel point non non attendez à tel
point qu'on soit à tel point qu'au soir
quand il a été élu il ce vote m'oblige
et je sais disait-il je le cite de
mémoire que beaucoup des gens qui ont
voté pour moi n'ont pas voté pour mes
idées ce que je veux dire c'est que
quand on est le président de la
République venant d'un grand pays on
doit comprendre que quand vous étiez lu
dans un rejet de l'extrême droite si
après vous dites aux gens ah c'est mon
programme de premier tour que j'applique
et bien
ça veut dire que Emmanuel Macron n'est
pas élu démocratiquement c'est pas élu
par la majorité
du peuple et comprendre qu'il y a des
choses sur lequel il faut le consulter
pas le brutaliser et au moins vérifier
qu'on est une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale je pensais qu'il a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale pour
voter ce texte
vous pensez qu'il va utiliser le
49-37 ans pourquoi pas pour pour un
temps pour que la forme de thé plus
rapidement s'il avait une majorité moi
je dis je demande à voir si les
républicains le groupe LR va voter en
majorité j'ai compris ce que faisait
monsieur cioti ça le concerne et je
respecte c'est un homme de droite tout à
fait conséquent à respectable mais
j'observe qu'il y a beaucoup de voix qui
s'élèvent chez les républicains parce
qu'ils sont en train de faire les
comptes aussi et de s'apercevoir
notamment vous savez il y a tout un
petit peuple de gens je dis petit de
manière extrêmement affectueuse de gens
qui ont travaillé dur qui votent à
droite ils sont en train de s'apercevoir
que c'est très propre
c'est possible que même le groupe LR ne
soit pas majoritairement avec lui et
qu'il fasse qu'ils doivent utiliser ce
49 3 déguisés quel 47 ans 49-3 tout
court c'est intéressant tout ça raison
de plus tout à l'heure pour dire qu'il y
a un moment pour débloquer la situation
pourquoi pas consulter le peuple le
peuple et moi je m'incline je me suis
toujours incliné la même façon que
Emmanuel Macron est président de la
République bah ça pourrait être une
issue mais d'abord retirer le texte je
pense que ça c'est plus sage un autre
sujet Adrien catenain c'est revenu à
l'Assemblée la semaine dernière après
avoir été condamné à quatre mois de
prison avec sursis pour violence
conjugales votre réaction à ce qu'a dit
Aurore berger qui a dit qu'il était
insupportable de siéger à côté de lui et
qu'elle ferait suspendre la séance
il a été déjà condamné par la loi il a
accepté il a fait une déclaration mon
groupe l'aradié jusqu'au 13 avril il a
été élu par des gens et je pense que
voilà il est député qu'est-ce que veut
madame berger elle considère que elle va
rajouter quelque chose de nouveau dans
la loi qui fait que on doit démissionner
ça 7 sanctions aurait pu être dans la
palette du juge 48 décision elle n'y est
pas après madame berger je veux pas être
parce que j'ai lu ça rapidement elle a
dans son propre groupe quelqu'un qui me
semble-t-il et dans une affaire un petit
peu délicate à l'heure actuelle avec des
femmes qui ont porté plainte contre lui
Damien Abad pour ne pas le nom je la
trouve moins pétaradante à ce sujet
il n'a pas été condamné pour l'instant
c'est peut-être la différence avec 90
même sur
juste vous parler de la loi
on parle d'un homme qui a été condamné
pour quatre mois avec sursis et qui est
pour l'instant nous qui ne fait plus
partie de notre groupe
est-ce que vous voterez sa proposition
de loi qui instaure une peine
complémentaire d'innéligibilité pour les
élus qui sont coupables de violences
conjugales je ne sais pas quel contenu
de cette loi elle est tellement
politicienne que sans doute que je vais
la combattre parce que je trouve qu'elle
est vraiment une instrumentalisation
d'un vrai sujet c'est-à-dire que dans
les c'est une instrumentalisation d'un
vrai sujet je vais vous dire la réalité
ce gouvernement contrairement à ce qu'il
a dit a mis moins de moyens pour la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes d'accord moins de moyens moins de
moyens matériels il y a toute une
lanuité des organisations et des
associations pardon qui luttent contre
les violences faites aux femmes qui
reprochent autant après beaucoup de
communication il y a pas les moyens
berger faire tourner actuellement
indépendamment de ça sur le principe sur
le principe le principe et bien de
randonner l'éligible un homme qui est
condamné pour violence conjugale sur le
principe imaginez que ça vienne de votre
groupe cette proposition vous savez un
juge peut aussi décider que vous ayez
une dignité il ne l'a pas rendu d'accord
donc dans le cas présent dont nous
parlons donc c'est inventer l'eau chaude
automaticité
estimé que notamment mais c'est pas
automatique voilà donc là elle veut le
rendre automatique par la loi parce que
dans la graduation des peines il y a
toute une série de choses qui doivent
être examinées
je veux bien qu'on fasse de ce sujet et
vraiment un sujet sensible mais je dis
je dis à Madame berger gare à
l'instrumentalisation que vous êtes en
train de faire on a bien compris
pourquoi vous faites ça ça manque
peut-être un petit peu dignité même si
après c'est un sujet sérieux merci
Brigitte je reviens un moment sur la
réforme des retraites sur les carrières
longues vont dénoncer une réforme
injuste ça m'intéresse parce que a
priori le dispositif est un peu
intéressant avant 16 ans c'est le même
tarif 58 ans avant 18 ans c'est 60 ans
entre 18 et 20 ans c'est 62 ans donc ce
sera deux ans avant les 64 ans c'est
plutôt une amélioration ça c'est à dire
que il y a deux ans de plus il y a deux
ans de plus qui vont être imposés et
ceux qui comment dirais-je sont dans les
dispositifs carrière longue ne feront
peut-être pas nécessairement ces deux
ans de plus dans la mesure où je sais
pas si je me fais comprendre ils ont
droit de partir dans le mais par rapport
à leur situation actuelle ça n'améliore
en rien je sais pas si je me suis fait
comprendre
deux années ça ne dégrade pas leur
situation quand vous dites c'est une
réforme donc non mais là il y a rien qui
bouge il y a pas d'amélioration si il y
a une petite amélioration on va pas
entrer dans les détails mais là par
exemple c'est un statut quoique un
minima c'est un statu quo donc elle est
pas juste la réforme ce qui est injuste
c'est que vous allez avoir des millions
de salariés qui vont travailler plantons
ceux qui sont nés en 1971 doivent 61
jusqu'en 1968 doivent comprendre que ça
accélère la la la réforme Touraine qui
était déjà prévu ça va amener à ce que
très rapidement des millions de gens
vont devoir travailler plus longtemps
qui était proche de la retraite ça oui
il y a beaucoup de gens qui vont
travailler plus longtemps on y reviendra
tout à l'heure avec
pas pour quelle raison faut infliger un
alourdissement des conditions de travail
de beaucoup de gens en particulier sur
ceux qui ont déjà travaillé longtemps
qui sont usés par le travail comment
dire je vous manque pas de respect parce
que c'est mon cas vous et moi sans doute
qu'on peut et on prendrait plaisir avoir
des tas d'activité une fois que l'âge de
la retraite mais pour plein de gens vous
le savez c'est quand même difficile
qui a accepté je vous remercie aussi
d'avoir d'ailleurs accepté le débat
Vincent on le retrouve tout à l'heure
après il trait que je salue qui est
entré sur ce plateau bonjour bonsoir
adjoint de la rédaction du Figaro c'est
à vous et bien merci alors il y a eu une
actualité assez riche je dirais pendant
le week-end à propos de la gauche et
notamment c'est interview dans le
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France de Madame
Hidalgo qui dit la France insoumise est
un parti non démocratique qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez que
chers madame Hidalgo vous avez mené
campagne élection présidentielle en
répétant peuple ou la même chose et à
l'arrivée cela vous a rapporté 1,7% des
suffrages donc si Madame Hidalgo qui
avait l'honneur et elle quand on est
maire de Paris c'est pas très compliqué
d'avoir une grande interview dans le
Parisien je pense qu'il lui était plus
comment dirais-je pertinent de se
concentrer à expliquer pourquoi la
réforme des retraites est fort comment
dirais-je dangereuse pour les parisiens
plutôt que de profiter de l'occasion
pour polémiquer encore avec nous moi
j'appelle à l'unité à l'heure actuelle
et donc je ne comprends pas cet intérêt
en permanence voilà de vouloir agiter
quelque chose qui est assez étonnant on
vous connaît brillant sur les plateaux
tout comme d'ailleurs vos vos collègues
de la France insoumise et puis vous avez
été foutu dehors de la direction de
votre partie et vous alors entre
guillemets qui est quand même des des
grandes gueules au sens au sens noble du
terme
madame madame garrideau votre votre
compagne et puis beaucoup d'autres vous
n'avez rien dit mais rien dit mais
comment vous pouvez accepter d'avoir été
traité comme ça comme si vous étiez dans
un parti stalinien non mais je crois pas
d'avoir rien dit d'ailleurs certains des
amis ont même trouvé que j'en ai trop
dit je croise j'ai eu notamment le monde
ça c'est pas entendu
je me suis beaucoup exprimé sur le sujet
je fais des suggestions pour que nous
évoluions dans une direction que je
pense qui sol plus les militants qui
amènent à ce que notre équipe
d'animation soit moins parlementaire etc
je l'ai dit publiquement c'est un débat
qui est en train d'avoir lieu qui a
occasionné un débat au sein de notre
groupe parlementaire un séminaire comme
nous appelons ça et la discussion va
continuer comprenez et franchement c'est
pas une astuce de ma part je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure madame Martichoux qui me
reproche un peu mais on est en pleine
bagarre des retraites moi je ferai une
erreur vis-à-vis des gens qui me font
confiance si je comment dirais si
j'occupais une partie du temps pour
essayer de me concentrer entièrement
pour convaincre ce pourquoi faut être
nombreux le 19 à parler des débats
internes France insoumise ce que j'ai
dit ce que j'ai dit c'est votre
électorat la preuve la preuve Monsieur
Mélenchon qui vient de faire une
émission de télévision une grande
émission de télévision l'émission phare
du pape français il fait moins d'un
million de téléspectateurs est-ce que
justement c'est pas le résultat de
pratique qui te sont plutôt libérés par
les Français alors
sincèrement je ne pense pas que
l'audience qui qui m'importe que ce qui
était attendu
pas je pense qu'il faut faire attention
à ce que la vie parlementaire ne nous
grignote pas complètement escale arrivée
notre direction soit uniquement composée
de députés de jeunes députés je dis
attention parce que c'est quelque chose
de classique dans le mouvement politique
moi vous savez avant d'être député je
l'ai été j'ai pris des gamelles
électorales par de l'expression trivial
j'ai travaillé comment saignant
attention à ce qu'on devienne pas
rapidement parlementaire est-ce que je
la vie vous voyez ce que je vais en
parler tout ça c'est important on va en
parler on va en parler avec ses
Corbières mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que vous avez un leader qui n'est
pas d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale
qui n'est plus parlementaire et vous
c'est vous qui menez le combat à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'il y a
pas un problème de génération d'une part
avec quelqu'un qui a fait peut-être son
temps c'est pas une insulte que de le
dire et puis avoir un discours qui est
un peu plus moderne et d'ailleurs
l'affaire cadenas en l'occurrence c'est
c'est pas vraiment moderne ça cette
histoire là donc est-ce que vous n'avez
pas renouvelé complètement votre votre
logiciel comme il faut aller je vais
essayer de démêler premièrement pour le
coup l'émission de France Télévisions
France 2 Jean-Luc Mélenchon parlons de
les enjeux de la forêt en Guyane la
crise écologique était dans certaines
points de vue malgré le fait qu'il a 71
ans extrêmement moderne en vérité
d'accord peut-être trop même par rapport
au fait que ça peut-être des concerts
des gens qui disaient tiens pourquoi il
ne prend pas la retraite alors qu'ils
nous parlait en jeu planétaire etc donc
vous savez moi je fais pas de jeunes
hein on peut avoir des gens qui ont un
certain âge notamment n'était pas loin
du Brésil en Guyane Lula il revient et
il semble être l'homme de la situation
au Brésil d'un pays extrêmement déchiré
donc moi je fais pas de jeunisme j'en
sais rien ce que je sais c'est que
Jean-Luc ils disent j'ai fait trois
campagnes il faut imaginer peut-être la
suite sans moi donc il faut qu'on ait
cette possibilité d'une discussion
tranquillement sur pas tellement les
personnes à ce stade parce qu'on va se
taper la tête non mais moi ce que
j'aurais souhaité je sors des questions
de personnes d'abord qu'on discute
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait comme score 7
millions de voix comment on fait pour
faire plus c'est des débats qui
compriment mon ami Ruffin avait un peu
lancé c'est intéressant c'est à dire 7
millions de voix concentré souvent dans
les zones urbaines concentré des
départements qui sont souvent ok
mais je pique le débat est stimulant
alors vous êtes d'accord avec ce débat
non non monsieur Ruffin et Monsieur
Roussel votre compagnoniste qui dit moi
je suis pour la France du travail pour
la gauche du travail plus que pour la
gauche des alertes très mauvaise façon
de poser le problème je pense non mais
de sa part c'est absurde parce que la
gauche des allocs les allocations c'est
des acquis du monde du travail donc la
Fabien fait vraiment fausse route moi ce
que je dis ce que je dis c'est que
d'abord ne pas perdre le son que nous
avons constitué voir comment on
progresse et ne pas oublier une chose
c'est une discussion que j'ai avec mon
ami François Ruffin les abstentionnistes
et comment la question de la démocratie
aussi la Cinquième République bouffe la
vie politique j'ai voulu un peu faudrait
consacrer une émission là-dessus je vous
fais une proposition moi je pense qu'il
faudra porter l'idée qu'il faut abolir
ce que j'appelle dans une formule la
monarchie présidentielle trop de pouvoir
concentré sur un discours que non non
pardon je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire une chose c'est que je pense que ça
fabrique vous avez une culture politique
vous comprendrez un bon appartisme
l'idée qu'il faut un sauveur pour le
pays et ce pays va finir par se donner
un personnage autoritaire pour dénuer la
situation l'histoire de France
républicain doit reprendre le fil y
compris de la critique de Gaston
monerville en 58 de dire attention au
futur cette élection présidentielle qui
donne l'impression qu'on cherche son
Sauveur nous rendons et même dans nos
propres rangs je vais vous le dire alors
parce qu'en permanence on cherche le
grand personnage le grand sauveur et
comme moi je veux d'abord revenir on
cherche le grand personnage on se
rapproche à Jean-Luc non c'est pas ce
que je suis en train de dire mais si on
se raccroche chaque fois qu'il y a un
débat qui consiste à dire c'est qui le
prochain candidat et cetera moi je dis
que c'est pas une bonne façon de prendre
la tension comprenez ce que je suis en
train de dire d'abord oui peut-être mais
vous savez je vais prendre une phrase de
Bernard Cazeneuve qui m'a amusé parce
qu'elle était juste les idées ne
traversent pas la salle toute seule il
faut les gens pour les porter si on a un
débat d'idées et bien des femmes et des
hommes les incarneront alors si
justement
revenons au Parlement
deux grands partis qui structurent le
débat parlementaire aujourd'hui la
France insoumise et le rassemblement
national s'oppose à cette réforme des
retraites est-ce que vous n'avez pas
peur qu'on Parlement je parle pas dans
la rue là je parle au Parlement et bien
d'être doublé par le rassemblement
national comme première force
d'opposition à cette réforme des
retraites je vais vous répondre et toute
ma sincérité oui je pense qu'il y a dans
la période qui vient les années qui
viennent si on fait pas notre travail la
possibilité que l'extrême droite
progresse et prenne le pouvoir en 2027
oui je le crois et comme moi j'aime la
France passionnément je n'ai pas envie
de ça pour mon pays je n'ai pas envie
que Madame Le Pen je la respecte comme
femme et je suis en radical des accords
avec ces idées je ne veux pas ça pour la
France et bien je le dis solennellement
si on fait pas notre travail si comme
les filles on n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux si comme nupes on se disloque et
on parle de second sujet et pour le dire
crûment si on n'est pas utile à
l'occasion de cette bataille sur les
retraites comme étant la force outils
utiles qui n'est pas ces petites
histoires devant mais qui aident le
peuple à se mobiliser à comprendre les
enjeux et bien nous serons balayés
l'histoire est cruelle est tragique pour
ceux qui ne servent à rien si à
l'inverse on joue notre boulot vous
savez c'est comme quand on prend la mer
si tu prends bien le vent même si ta
fraise ton bateau était pas très grand
mais tu prends bien le vent tu vas très
loin là je dis que le vent va souffler
donc je dis à tous mes amis y compris
par rapport au débat internet à la
France insoumise et que ceux qui
m'écoutent comprennent bien moi à
l'heure actuelle je suis 100 % dévoué à
la bataille sur les retraites ça veut
pas dire que j'ai changé d'idée sur les
critiques ou les suggestions vous
reconnaissez-vous vous pouvez vous faire
doubler par le rassemblement national
pardon l'expression triviale si on
apparaît comme des gens pinailleur et
bien l'extrême droite peut d'accord sur
la base de l'idée que j'ai dit c'est à
dire il faut un personnage énergique qui
va fiché dehors etc les étrangers
une une question sur le Parti socialiste
on le voit très diviser à l'occasion de
son vote interne aux parties avec une
partie une fraction on va dire la moitié
du parti qui est contre la nupesse en
gros c'est ça ça vous fait ça vous vous
redoutez pas ça un peu je me suis fait
tancer parce que j'ai fait un tweet ce
weekend ou à présent d'émission dans
lequel j'ai dit que j'étais plutôt pour
sur le candidat le beaucoup de
socialisme madame rabot m'a dit
Corbières ne te mêle pas des débats de
participer donc je ne m’emmêle pas mais
vu de l'extérieur moi qui aime la
nupette qui pense que c'est qu'il doit
continuer je le redis j'espère que
chacun comprendra que je n'exerce aucune
pression sur les adhérents du parti
socialiste que je suis pour que ce soit
le candidat le polygone donc vous l'avez
dit voilà mais après les militants
socialistes choisiront maintenant la
réalité c'est que si on veut l'Union il
faut le faire avec les gens qui
composent les forces c'est donc avec
nous et je crois que c'est une bonne
chose il faut continuer comme ça c'est
un des enjeux de la semaine aussi pour
vous bien résultat jeudi 22h merci frère
on rejoint Vincent roux en direct du
Fier en live bonsoir Vincent pardon pour
le retard mais la question reste
évidemment très pertinente on vous
écoute Vincent bonsoir Elisabeth oui il
faut être un petit peu militaire c'est
ce que disait tout à l'heure
avec si Corbières bonsoir Alexis
Corbière ben alors précisément c'est un
débat qui agite la majorité c'est le
port de l'uniforme à l'école Brigitte
Macron est pour Papen DIY et contre
alors vous avez du côté de Brigitte
Macron ou
s'il faut choisir comme ça plutôt du
côté de papel Diagne mais que les choses
soient claires
aujourd'hui l'école publique c'est le
socle de la République elle est en train
d'être disloquée selon les quartiers où
vous habitez ça n'est plus la même école
publique franchement donc on est moi
j'avais repris le terme il y a une forme
de séparatisme scolaire qui se met en
place dernièrement des chercheurs du
CNRS avaient mis en place l'indice de
positionnement social l'IPS et qui nous
disait clairement que selon les les
collèges il y a des IPS il y a une
polarisation extrêmement forte des
catégories les plus aisées qui vont dans
certains endroits des catégories les
plus modestes qui se concentre dans
d'autres et y compris point de temps la
concurrence rude est-ce que l'uniforme
répond à partir c'est ça qu'il faut
corriger n'est pas quand il y a le
cacher uniquement par une tenue c'est à
dire que faire croire qu'on va combattre
les inégalités à l'école parce que les
gamins vont tous porter le même t-shirt
et le même jupette c'est totalement
passé à côté du sujet c'est comme si je
disais Monsieur Bernard Arnault
aujourd'hui gagne en 6 secondes autant
que non qu'un an de travail de smicard
mais je propose que Monsieur Bernard
Arnault s'habille comme un ouvrier on
aura combattu les inégalités comme
jambes néanmoins est-ce que c'est et je
rappelle que dans toute l'histoire de la
République ça n'est jamais arrivé parce
que j'entends dire des choses qui ne
sont totalement fausses
République même les hussards noirs
aujourd'hui ne proposait pas ça mais
aujourd'hui on a les yeux noirs de la
République française
vous êtes vous avez tout à fait raison
et vous êtes historien ça n'a jamais été
obligatoire Question quand même puisque
vous êtes attaché à l'égalité est-ce que
vous ne pas sensible à cette argument
que ça peut gommer les différences et
être un outil comme disait Elisabeth un
outil d'égalité l'argument que j'entends
et je mets ma casquette de papa qui est
trois enfants et trois filles c'est que
la tyrannie des marques c'est
insupportable ça c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un vrai sujet donc comment on
combat tout ça comment on combat
éventuellement ces influenceurs sur les
réseaux qui amènent à ce que sur plein
de sujets mais y compris parfois fente
de d'embrigadement religieux qui peut
imposer problème ça ça m'intéresse comme
discussion d'accord mais c'est pas
simple ceci dit à gérer je sais pas
comment on y arrive aujourd'hui à régler
parce que précisément c'est pas un moyen
d'y arriver non je ne crois pas je pense
que ça n'aura que pour rester une fois
de plus que de déguiser des problèmes
plutôt que de les régler merci Vincent
on vous retrouve tout à l'heure pour une
autre question d'actualité en face de
vous Benjamin date qu'on est très
heureux de recevoir merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté le principe du
débat vous êtes député de Paris élu de
la majorité Renaissance majorité
relative au Parlement rajoute parce que
sinon on va se prendre un TAC
benjamindaq vous avez d'abord voulu
évidemment commencer par le sujet de la
semaine et pas seulement de la semaine
la réforme des retraites c'est à VOUS
Corbière bonne année
je voulais vous interroger sur la forme
de retraite moi je suis né en 1985 donc
les gens de ma génération vont prendre
leur retraite d'ici un peu moins de 30
ans peupro et quand j'entends vos prises
de position sur cette réforme je me
demande si ce que vous nous souhaitez au
fond et c'est la question je voulais
vous poser c'est de cotiser un système
par capitalisation parce que vous êtes
historien on a en France un système de
redistribution un système de répartition
de solidarité intergénérationnelle ou
les actifs cotisent pour les retraités
actuels c'est l'héritage du CNR c'est
l'héritage aussi des combats de gauche
dans notre République et aujourd'hui on
a en France de taux de retraite le temps
de retraite le plus élevé de ce 25 ans
une démographie qui s'allonge et donc il
faut faire comme tous nos voisins
européens y compris les gouvernements de
gauche comme en Espagne où ils sont
passés à 67 ans il faut allonger un peu
collectivement l'âge de départ à la
retraite pourquoi c'est la seule façon
de sauver ce système par répartition et
donc je m'interroge oui la gauche oui la
gauche pour se battre pour notre système
par répartition où est la gauche pour se
battre pour les retraites minimales pour
une meilleure prise en compte des
carrières longues des carrières pénibles
de l'inégalité entre les hommes et les
femmes
en choisissant le mensonge à démagogie
en faisant croire que cette réforme
n'est pas nécessaire pour pérenniser
pour lutter contre les déficites pour
sauver notre système par répartition
vous nous condamnez soit la faillite
soit des systèmes comme on a aux
États-Unis c'est-à-dire capitalisation
chacun épargne pour lui-même il met en
bourse avec les inégalités et la
sécurité
ma question c'est est-ce que vous voulez
pas au fond condamner ma génération et
les générations suivantes à une faillite
de notre système par répartition et à
une retraite par capitalisation
le constat la charge est sévère mais je
vous remercie de votre franchise bon
vous avez dit 25 ans dans d'âge de
d'années après la retraite moyen je vous
rappelle que ça c'était sous Nicolas
Sarkozy mais avec les réformes des
retraites qui sont engagées on est déjà
à 24 ans et les études du corps nous
disent qu'avec la réforme que vous
soutenez on va passer sans doute à 23
ans c'est à dire que la durée de vie
après la retraite diminue dans un pays
où vous ne pouvez pas ça vous a pas
échappé parce que c'est un parlementaire
assidu on en a beaucoup parlé cet été ce
qui éclate aux yeux des Français c'est
la question aussi des des surpris il y a
beaucoup de richesses dans ce pays ce
pays n'a jamais été aussi riche il faut
féliciter les travailleurs français qui
sont extrêmement productifs donc la
question pour défendre notre système par
répartition c'est aussi pourquoi pas
d'imaginer un autre partage pour quelle
raison dans la réforme que vous proposez
il n'est jamais abordé le fait
qu'eventuellement les employeurs fassent
qui une cotisation qui si à l'augmenter
de 0,7% pourraient permettre que tout se
passe parfaitement bien et que notamment
le seul effort que vous proposez vous
c'est en direction des travailleurs mais
certainement pas des entreprises vous
savez notre système il est paritaire il
y a double cotisations il y a une
cotisation qui est de la part des
travers mais aussi de l'entreprise vous
vous imaginez les choses que en termes
de c'est les travailleurs qui doivent
faire les efforts et votre politique
elle a une forme de cohérence c'est de
dire il faut surtout pas toucher le
moindre effort de la part des
entreprises les entreprises pour lequel
ça peut être difficile mais à d'autres
qui peuvent tout à fait le faire alors
pourquoi la raison devrait laisser se
creuser des inégalités avec des
surprofits totalement sidérants qui
stupéfient l'ensemble des Français et
n'avoir qu'une chose à dire à nos
concitoyens c'est vous devez travailler
plus loin
si vous travaillez plus longtemps ça va
produire une chose c'est qu'il y a des
gens qui n'y arriveront pas parce que
d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui vous le savez
très bien on n'a pas la totalité de nos
de nos années si vous y mettez deux ans
de plus et bien les gens n'arriveront
pas au terme de toutes ces années donc
il y aura des retraites incomplètes et
après on va assister on y assistes déjà
depuis qu'on est passé de 60 à 62 ans
c'est que les gens n'ayant pas la
totalité de leur de leur annuité la nos
pensions vont baisser et qu'est-ce qui
va se développer pardon je termine parce
que de manière de vous répondre on va y
venir au fait que ça va être le business
des assurances privées et finalement
c'est un peu l'idée qui est derrière
c'est que comme les pensions vont être
petit et bien si vous allez avoir des
gens notamment vers les quatre qui vont
dire sur le premier point donc
effectivement j'entends que c'est un
élément de langage de la nups depuis
quelques jours c'est de dire après tout
il suffit d'augmenter les cotisations
parce que c'est vrai d'ailleurs c'est
une des solutions à cet égard je vous
céderai au moins de ne pas dire les
déficits les dettes ça compte pas on va
juste les transférer générations futures
combien Benjamin ça compte combien
est-ce que c'est vrai qu'il y a trois
barres le vrai on parle vrai ça compte
combien je vous réponds il y a trois
leviers bah attendez ça coûte combien
par exemple là le corps nous dit avec
une hypothèse quand même d'ailleurs de
chômage à quatre et demi pour cent donc
en fait une hypothèse spécifique
optimiste nous dit 12 milliards de
déficit en 2027 avec 150 milliards de
déficitations accumulés d'ici
pourcentage ça fait combien d'ici 15 ans
en pourcentage ça fait combien bah ça
fait 17 %, ça fait 3 %. non les
retraites les retraits
les retraites représentent 17% du PIB en
France par exemple c'est je crois 12% en
Allemagne donc ça représente plus en
France que chez la plupart de nos
voisins qui ont fait cet effort c'est un
problème là je sais pas mais c'est un
problème parce que on veut pouvoir le
pérenniser l'équilibré veut pouvoir être
sûr que ce système il va bénéficier
général
des cotisations parce que effectivement
il y a d'autres leviers soit on baisse
le montant des pensions nous on veut
faire l'inverse on veut au contraire
revaloriser les pensions minimales à 85
% du SMIC c'était à 1100 €, soit
effectivement on augmente les
cotisations les cotisations dans un pays
où on a déjà le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire le plus élevé de l'OCDE et
d'ailleurs on a un peu commencé une
trajectoire à la baisse de ces
prélèvements obligatoires de ces impôts
sur les entreprises et de ses
cotisations par exemple pour les jusqu'à
1,6 fois le SMIC c'est ce qui nous a
fait augmenter
mais c'est ce qui nous a permis de faire
de faire baisser le chômage le taux de
chômage le plus faible en 15 ans le taux
d'emploi le plus important en 25 ans ce
qui fait qu'en réalité quand on regarde
les cotisations les recettes des
cotisations elles ont augmenté ces
dernières années donc en réalité vous
vous voulez faire des taux punitifs qui
vont faire partir les emplois qui vont
faire grandir les investissements et on
va se retrouver en fait avec des
cotisations qui vont diminuer alors
Olivier
sur la réforme
mais vous dites les prélèvements
obligatoires mais moi je suis fier
d'être dans un pays des prélèvements
obligatoires parce que les pays j'ai vu
je vous connais un peu vous avez bien
connu les États-Unis etc dans des pays
où il y a des faibles ce qu'on appelle
des prélèvements obligatoires il faut
tout payer il faut payer l'école il faut
payer l'hôpital moi attention c'est des
cotisations bien souvent c'est une belle
idée l'idée de la cotisation donc faut
pas faire peur au moins nous en disant
on a le plus fort taux de de cotisations
de prélèvement obligatoire mais c'est
parce que aujourd'hui y compris il a
baissé ces dernières années il était
plus fort il y a quelques temps est-ce
que les Français est-ce que les Français
pensent aujourd'hui l'hôpital va mieux
est-ce que les Français passent que
l'école va mieux moi le sentiment que
j'ai je sais pas que de vous là où vous
habitez où là où vous êtes élus mais je
veux dire le sentiment général c'est pas
que nos services publics et l'État
aujourd'hui fonctionnent mieux qu'il y a
quelques années en raison du fait que
des gens comme vous
mais pas du tout mais précisément mais
c'est très intéressant ce que vous êtes
en train de dire parce qu'effectivement
on a le taux de prélèvement obligatoire
le plus important on a le taux de après
le Danemark important et pourtant vous
le dites vous-même l'éducation nationale
la santé on a des défis immense est-ce
que c'est juste une question dépense
publique est-ce qu'on peut vraiment mais
sincèrement se regarder et dire que le
problème qu'on a avec par exemple la
France qui baisse dans les classements
pizza sur les mathématiques ou la
lecture ou l'écriture est-ce que c'est
uniquement moi c'est quoi parce qu'on a
les enseignants les plus mal payés de
l'OCDE c'est quoi d'après vous c'est
quoi d'après vous ah bah c'est lié
peut-être une conversation
on est le pays qui dépense le plus par
habitant sur l'éducation nationale donc
ayons un débat à ce moment-là sur
l'organisation notre éducation nationale
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a aucun
lien avec le fait qu'on a en place et
c'est ce qu'on a réussi à faire
d'ailleurs en découpant les classes au
CP CE1 et là on a obtenu des résultats
mais vous nous suivez jamais je vous
entends parler de pouvoir d'achat mais
tout à l'heure là vous disiez il faut
apaiser le pays mais vous n'avez pas
voté avec nous les mesures pour le
pouvoir d'achat pour précisément
protéger les Français aux Français
le blocage des prix de première
nécessité
je pense qu'aujourd'hui en termes de
pouvoir d'achat vous avez protégé en
cette rentrée bien sûr que bon c'est pas
le sentiment que l'inflation est trop
fort mais vous alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez fait qu'est-ce que vous avez autour
de nous on a le taux d'inflation le plus
faible de la zone euro attendez on
serait on serait chez certains nos
voisins ou aux États-Unis effectivement
que je connais bien et j'en vois bien
d'ailleurs les limites de ce modèle
social ou plutôt ce modèle antisocial là
ils sont dans une spirale inflationniste
donc évidemment et vous ne l'avez pas de
la même façon que vous ne voulez pas
aujourd'hui vous engagez à protéger le
financement de notre système par
répartition
je reviens sur les retraites pour pas
qu'on perde de fil vous savez les
politiques que vous avez menées à ce
qu'il y ait moins de recettes le
problème dont jeunes du système des
retraites
le rapport du corps c'est le problème
c'est un rapport c'est pas un problème
de dépenses des dépenses sont maîtrisées
ce que dit le rapport du corps si vous
l'avez lu c'est que c'est un problème de
recettes j'espère que ça vous dites pas
que c'est faux est-ce que c'est faux
déclinant par exemple de cotisations
notamment qui est dû au fait que les
gens comme vous pardon vous prend comme
ça partie vous allez baissé vous avez
exonéré de cotisations pour près de 2
milliards il y a 2 milliards en moins de
recettes mais par exemple c'est qu'on a
un taux d'emploi des seniors qui est
trop faible c'est bien sûr comment vous
allez le régler mais attends vous
regardez tous les pays autour de nous on
est regardé on est le pays qui parle
allemand je suis en train de vous
répondre on est le pays qui parle à la
retraite le plus tôt et on est le pays
on est très en dessous de la moyenne
européenne sur le taux d'emploi des
seniors nos voisins qui décalage de
départ à la retraite qui travaille tout
ce collectivement un petit peu plus
longtemps
ils ont une présence des signaux déjà de
façon automatique alors ça suffit pas
mais de façon automatique les
entreprises conservent les seniors en
entreprise plus longtemps quand vous
avez un décalage de l'âge de départ et
après effectivement il y a des
mécanismes moi je crois que c'est ce
qu'on va faire il faut favoriser le
cumul emploi retraite et la cotisation
pour la retraite quand on fait le cumul
emploi retraite il faut favoriser les
formations tout au long de la ville il y
a un très bon rapport par exemple du
Sénat qui que les seniors sont ceux qui
utilisent le moins les formations
souvent d'ailleurs parce que les
entreprises
mais quand on est passé de 60 à 60 ans
d'ailleurs combien la proportion de
seniors qu'on a dans les entreprises
donc comparons-nous autour de nous je
veux dire à un moment on a un taux
d'emploi des seigneurs qui est plus
faible on parle plutôt donc on voit bien
autour de nous vous vouliez aborder
aussi un autre thème donc il reste 3
minutes donc la réponse on est le seul
avant un système par répartition tous
les autres sont capitalisation et par
ailleurs les retraités en Allemagne sont
beaucoup plus maltraités que que les
notes donc moi je veux bien les
comparaisons on a plus le temps je vous
en fais pas reproche mais vous savez
très bien qu'en réalité il y a aucun
système qui est très inspirant autour de
nous et je pense qu'il faut défendre le
système français donc des fois le
système français ensemble oui mais alors
pour quelle raison elle évolue arrêtons
les exonérations moi je veux regarder en
discutant tous les deux on peut
rapporter 2 milliards de plus pour le
système de retraite arrêter les
exonérations de cotisation pour des
entreprises qui n'ont pas mené de
politique sociale ça c'est vous qui
l'avez décidé
et j'ai été un peu déçu de constater que
la France insoumise est d'assez loin le
groupe qui est le moins représenté dans
ce groupe d'amitié je crois qu'il y a
qu'un seul membre de votre partie bon on
va dire c'est peut-être anecdotique mais
vous avez aussi vous êtes abstenu
lorsque nous avons présenté une
résolution de soutien à l'Ukraine et
d'ailleurs le seul député à avoir voté
contre cette résolution est aussi un
membre de la France insoumise Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a fait beaucoup de
déclarations pour dire qu'il ne fallait
pas livrer d'armes à l'Ukraine c'était
réjouit l'annexion de la Crimée en
disant c'est ça que le temps n'aura pas
il avait dit c'est une bonne nouvelle je
cite c'est une bonne nouvelle ah si si
vous pouvez vérifier d'ailleurs vous
pouvez faire le fake checking maintenant
si vous voulez c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est toujours ça que le temps n'aura
pas bon peu importe moi je voudrais vous
demander aujourd'hui quel est votre
position sur le soutien à l'Ukraine les
sanctions les livraisons d'armes un pays
qui est en proie à une agression
violente d'un état extérieur est-ce que
si demain Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
président Alexis Corbière ministre sa
face est-ce que la France avec ses
partenaires continuer à soutenir
l'Ukraine ou est-ce qu'on se retirer
tout cela et on rejoindrait l'alliance
bolivarienne par exemple avec l'Iran et
la Russie
ça vous pouvez éviter dans votre
programme non ça dépend dans votre
programme mais je sais bien que vous
faut se tenir au courant et par ailleurs
bon bref passons c'est vraiment
une réponse assez bref c'est possible
je suis du côté je pense que Poutine et
l'agresseur dans cette histoire faut
apporter notre solidarité à l'Ukraine
telle que nous l'avons dit actuellement
pour ce qui est la question des armes
qui est une question sensible je vais
vous dire que vous ce qu'a fait la
France jusqu'à présent me va c'est à
dire aider les
Ukrainiens mais ne pas participer à une
spirale belliqueuse qui amène à ce que
la France elle-même
c'est des sujets sur lequel on peut en
parler tous les trois mais ça nécessite
une certaine comment est finesse vous
voyez ce que je veux dire moi ce que je
veux pas et vous aussi j'en doute pas et
je pense que les Français c'est qu'on
veut apporter notre solidarité à
l'Ukraine l'agresseur c'est Poutine je
pense qu'il faut même prendre des
initiatives diplomatiques pour essayer
de réunir des longtemps à ta même si
c'est difficile je suis pour sanctionner
rudement tous les oligarques russes et
on peut continuer à le faire plus fort
que ce qu'on a fait et en matière d'aide
matérielle qu'il faut apporter je ne
suis pas pour que la France se retrouve
dans une spirale à rentrer en guerre
avec la aussi j'avoue que ça nécessite
un certain poids de dire non mais
j'entends c'est ma position c'est un peu
l'élément du rassemblement national de
dire aussi on peut devenir
corbelligérant sur l'île des armes mais
c'est faux personne ne veut envoyer des
trous par exemple en
ukrainement
puisque vous dites qu'on est tous
d'accord pour quelle raison vous voyez
une ambiguïté dans ce qui peut vous en
vérité la position de la France que si
c'est parce que je n'ai pas entendu si
votre position c'est soutenir la
position de la France à ce moment-là
effectivement c'est très clair mais ce
n'est pas la position
mais ce qui n'était pas par ailleurs là
ce qui n'était pas l'objet de la
résolution que vous avez présenté
peut-être que là on est en train de se
perdre et technique mais qui était plus
médico en vérité que la diplomatie
française parce que vous vous étiez pour
que nombre de pays rentrent dans l'OTAN
et le problème y compris si l'Ukraine
rentre dans l'OTAN c'est qu'à partir du
moment c'est qu'il y avait pas la
candidature de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN dans
le solidarité avec les pays qui nous
entraîne dans une il y avait pas la
candidature il y avait celle de la Suède
et la Finlande effectivement et notre
Assemblée nationale et ça c'est la
position de la France et du soutien à
l'Ukraine TF1 donc cher Benjamin dan on
peut discuter de soutien l'Ukraine sans
qu'il n'y a-t-on me demande aussi au
passage de valider
l'entrée de la Suède et de la Finlande
dans l'OTAN donc voyez ce Mélenchon est
toujours été contre les livraisons de
matériel donc vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec le je vous assure ben écoutez sur
France 2
je vous assure maintenant lorsque si
vous désintégrer il y a pas de problème
mais effectivement la position que je
m'exprimer là celle de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon une aide pourquoi pas mais pas
une aide qui amène à ce qu'on soit comme
éligérant
on va rejoindre tout de suite Vincent
roux en direct du Fier life pour une
ultime question d'actualité Vincent oui
question d'actualité puisque c'est un
texte qui va être discuté à partir de
demain au Sénat qui vise à éviter que
les futurs chantiers nucléaires soit
freiné par les procédures
c'est la question qu'on pose aujourd'hui
sur le site du Figaro Alexis Corbière
est-ce qu'il faut faciliter
l'installation de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires en France
à ce stade si ce texte il s'agit de
dérèglementer tout ce qui est norme
écologique etc je n'y suis pas favorable
je pense qu'on peut avoir une politique
industrielle et vous connaissez ma
position sur le nucléaire mais moi je
suis pour y compris développer d'autres
sources d'énergie mais je ne vois pas
pour quelle raison
de remettre en cause des réglementations
qui vont avoir des conséquences
écologiques donc je n'y suis pas
favorable peut-être que vous me le
présentez à ce stade est-ce que vous
pouvez juste repréciser votre position
sur la question nucléaire mais vous le
savez ça a été porté pendant la campagne
présidentielle par Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
nucléaire a assuré pendant des années
une forme d'indépendance énergétique de
la France le nucléaire a certaines
limites et nous sommes plutôt favorables
à ce que dans le cas de ce qu'on appelle
le scénario dit negawatts porté par
nombre de scientifiques à ce que la
France c'est un grand projet industriel
s'engage vers une sortie de nucléaire
aux alentours de 2050 2060 c'est
ambitieux mais ça veut dire avoir une
filière nationale une filière aussi
actuellement qui incite à
apprendre cette trajectoire on n'a pas
le temps de développer mais ce qu'on vit
actuellement démontre aussi qu'il y a eu
que le nucléaire se dégrade coûte plus
cher que prévu qu'on n'a pas amélioré
cet outil de production Vincent roux à
la semaine prochaine pardon on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine le temps
et compter comme on dit Benjamin merci
encore d'avoir accepté le débat merci
beaucoup Alexis Corbière d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à auditions publiques à
très vite sur LCP on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à 19h30 sur LCP et
Public Sénat bien sûr bonne semaine à
tous
[Musique]